[Music]
hello and welcome to film independent
presents i'm rachel blimer director of
events for film independent before we
get started with today's very exciting q
a i have to give some support to our
loyal supporters uh thank you for the
incredible uh
uh support from hollywood foreign press
association and our screening partner
vision media and with that i'm honored
to introduce today's guest moderator
please help me welcome kelly curtis
kelly please take it from here
hello good afternoon and welcome today
i'm moderating a conversation for the
film independent which of course
produces the film independent spirit
awards which recognizes the finest
achievements of american independent
filmmakers film independent recently
broke into covering the awards
television series space and has a
history of recognizing auteur and
character-driven stories which of course
brings us to today's panel i'm kelly
carter senior entertainment reporter for
espn's undefeated it's my absolute honor
to moderate a conversation with the
creators and cast of stars most
excellent new series bmf when we was
growing up we wanted to be like young
boys incorporated
all them dudes had money women clothes
and fly whips
but more than anything
they had respect
letting my brother in the car with me
that day
took us on a journey beyond our wildest
imaginations
yeah we got a product that created this
on demand as long as we got my vision
and your brains
can't nobody mess with us man
and without further ado i want to bring
in this excellent team i want to start
with curtis 50 cent jackson executive
producer and a director welcome thank
you
absolutely randy huggins what up though
to my detroit native uh who's the show
runner and executive producer and writer
for this series what up though what up
dao da vinci who is terry southwest t
flinnery hello da vinci
what up though what up though what up no
hello michael brianna white uh who's the
matriarch uh lucille flenery in the
series
what up though
what up though to steve harris who is
detective bryant in bmf
what up though hello
and last but most certainly not least
what up though to demetrius little meech
flintery jr who is the son of demetrius
big meech flinnery whom he portrays in
the series what up though little meech
yeah what up though
so you know i have shared this with 50
before but as a woman originally from
detroit i've been waiting for at least
15 years for someone to bring this story
to life i always thought it would work
so well as a film but my god it works so
much better told in serial form randy i
want to start with you at what point did
this come to you as a project and what
was it about this story that worked for
you and made you want to create
uh 50 and i worked together on power the
first three seasons and i think season
three i was leaving and i was working on
an episode with him and he was like yo i
got the bmf joint so i'm sitting there
like i know he's about to ask me to do
it but he didn't you know what i mean he
had two other guys so i left and i went
and did like a couple other shows and he
called me like two years later and he
like yo what's up you want to do it and
i'm like heck yeah you know what i mean
so he turned me on to meech and we
started talking and i'm visiting him in
prison for like
you know three or four times and uh what
really made me want to do this was that
um
once i started talking to meech i found
out that this was more than like a drug
show sort of you know sort of speak it
was really a show about family about
brotherhood about love and about
spirituality and it was a show about
detroit and i think that's one of the
biggest things i wanted to do make
detroit a character the same way
uh baltimore is a character and wire
laser character and snowfall so it was
an opportunity for me to bring my uh
shine some light on my hometown as well
as these two brothers who were probably
the most
uh the biggest two street legends to
ever come out of this city yeah
absolutely fifty why was now the right
time to tell the stories you know randy
just said that y'all have been talking
about this for several years before we
actually saw it why is now the time
well the the stars lined up for us and
as far as the cat
is concerned like but they all fell
together the perfect timing because
the like i had this series well i sold
it to stars four and a half years ago
so
the process
allowed me to to make choices that are
not traditional choices as far as
getting
the the crew together for it and then
you know like i was able to get steve
and wood in the in the frame at one time
like that's like look this is magic like
this is
and then to get mccole and russell
working together they already have a
prior history of working and making
moments that you couldn't
you don't even have to put it on the
page these things are the lines were
written but what you see in performance
you can't put that there without
russell and nicole there you know and
there's a different
energy even even miles the characters
that already
already
died after the show they they brought
things like
his scene didn't have the spritz of the
hairspray in it it was something that he
brought to it the added humor to the
moment
yeah and you know like these are
extremely talented people in the cast it
makes me look like a genius later
story organically coming from a
fictional story uh a crime
drama family related story in power to a
true story the difference is
in the true story is spirituality is
christianity
that's the theme that runs through the
show that isn't in the other
raising canaan or in uh
ghosts or any of these shows yeah
[Music]
you know i can't say enough how well
done bmf is and i know that randy is
from detroit and and to me once i saw
that once i knew that that's why the the
entire series felt so authentic to me
and really like the most authentic piece
of work i've seen about my hometown um
in decades um i want to bring in the
actress here because by now you guys
know that people not only back home are
appreciating the nuances and the need to
not overexplain detroit in a way we
don't ever get to see happen in
hollywood but people really just love
the work that you guys
do um i want to know how that
authenticity helped you guys with your
performances and and what that was like
uh for you guys as you were bringing
these very real characters to life uh
why don't we start with you uh little
meech
uh it was amazing just bringing my
character to life just because it was my
dad and 50 actually you know put me
acting classes so i could learn how to
be an actor so it was different you know
me just jumping in for the first time
and i have to you know learn the
childhood history of how my dad grew up
you know we grew up two totally
different lifestyles so me having to
play him at that young in a detrimental
time of detroit you know the 19 1980s
back then it was different so
me just you know developing that and
you know and using what my dad was
telling me every day
to my to my ability it was you know just
like basically just just so helpful for
me and so and it made me comfortable in
what i was doing
yeah
and he actually when i brought up he
found out that mitch was that i wanted
him to play the character he was like oh
can you act
because he didn't even know that i
already sent him
to like we we kept that from him
at the time until we i knew he could
actually make the cut like after we got
so many progress reports i was excited
by and the team of the cast everyone
that's around them is why he's receiving
the praise that he's receiving because
yeah the strongest support system of
talented artists around them they made
them look things that would specifically
he said something tournament it stuck
with me i took it with me he said
perform with listening eyes remember he
was on that call
yeah
everything that that was being said i
was saying you got to pay attention to
it listen what they're saying because
they know what they're doing they've
been doing this the entire time you know
what i'm saying but there
and and then four minutes later it's
great like you know as soon as you walk
out because culturally he's a part of
what's hip already
so it gives the show a life that
other television shows don't have when
he's out he's moving around he's on
premise in different places and people
get to touch and feel him in a different
way and it's almost like he's he's a new
version of what his dad was at that
point because he'd be giant he'd be
having all his diamonds on everything
and we gotta get davinci out there
because he's not he's not
like that but we're gonna we're gonna
get that going
i'm trying to ask me someone to change
but mitchell won't give it to
well you know 50 you're absolutely right
in that uh this this uh series is just
stacked with really excellent um talent
i want to bring in steve harris and
mccoll because uh you guys
you know you guys have been doing this
for a while i know nicole you're also a
broadway queen but but talk to me about
you know bringing these characters to
life especially you know with how
authentic this story is to what was that
like for you guys as actors working on
this project
um i'll say for me um
i just want to start off by saying i'm
so honored um to be a part of this
product project
and um and to play miss lucille and to
have the opportunity to play
someone a real person that i actually
get to talk to who's with us that's i've
never had that experience before
and um
um so that was really um amazing to me
to be able to you know talk to her even
in between scenes and and things and
have her send me you know she would send
me bible verses you know in between or
to help uh encourage me when i felt
nervous or whatever sometimes even
and um
and just you know the story itself is
just so authentic and it's also an honor
to be able to
um
stand with lil meach and uh help usher
him into this world um and and playing
his father to really support him through
this journey has been really
um amazing and um with all of these
um
young people that we're working with
it's just been a joy and an honor uh and
da vinci as well to just be able to
support them and and help lift them up
into this new place and
um
anyway it's just all been amazing i i
can't even find all the words it's
extraordinary
yeah steve how about yourself yeah if
you did a good job don't worry though
uh let me just say uh so first off i
wanted to do this you know what i mean
when they when they brought it to me man
you remember we was talking the first
thing i had a couple questions that i
want to have
one was i wanted detroit to be there and
be alive because we i'm from chicago
which is
a better part of the midwest but we
ain't talking about it
but uh uh but i wanted to be a part of
it because i knew
i i knew the story i knew the people you
know was a time when i was doing my
thing so i really wanted to be a part of
it and then when you when you actually
get to
the fact that you include my brother and
he was talking to me even before they
came yo man he hit me up on the phone
like
hey this is
and i was like okay
let me hear what they got to say and uh
and then we got the rapping and it was
it was
uh as up as i told randy and i ain't
told video but it was it's one of the
highlights of my career i've been around
for a minute the opportunity to play
opposite my brother was such a big deal
and i didn't even know how how much of a
deal it was going to be
and then to actually tell this story to
me i think it's important for us to get
the story out i don't think we should be
run away from our stories this is one of
our stories and i think we we should
tell it and like i said my character i
think is a blend of a few cats from that
day
um in order to make it happen uh i'm
always trying to find something that
makes people uncomfortable when i do it
this he makes people uncomfortable um i
think the history of my sort of careers
uh i'm the one you love to hate kinda
sometimes so i sort of relish in that
[ __ ] i kind of start relishing that
stuff i kind of like it
so you know uh i just wanna i wanna say
and and i want to say something to add
on to nicole already said so eloquently
the the young cats bringing in that fuel
bringing in that young energy during the
time of a pandemic when they kind of try
to lock you out and all this other stuff
you're trying to do in order to make
that happen you need that fuel and the
the drive and the hustle that these cats
were doing
on the show
um
really helped keep everything going and
everybody sort of fired up
you know what i mean when you've been
around for a minute you that young thing
to go along with the best that was a
great combination
um figure is right on point when he said
it earlier you know he had a plan and i
did he's very modest with it this time
which you know what
but his plan came through you know he
put people around the young cats bring
that energy and talent i don't want to
leave out talent
to both you cats as well as other
members on the show that i've said
before and you bring that all together
you end up having the success that this
show had
or has i should say and hopefully we'll
continue to have and that that
commitment
that started four and a half years ago
with them two caps
to actually put the best piece out there
to represent detroit as well as bmf
um sometimes the weight is righteous
and i think the weight was righteous
yeah but let's bring in one of those
young cats that was on the set benchy
talk to me
talk to me about you know bringing
bringing tea um the younger version of
tea to life in this series and because
he really also felt like you couldn't
have told me this dude was from uh
southwest detroit uh the way that you
brought him
honestly i appreciate you know 50 and
randy for even like
having this opportunity created for me
to even you know hop on board on a
project like this you know because i
mean
it's very seldom an actor's career you
get to play a real life story you know
what i'm saying and the character that
i'm playing like he's still alive which
is dope and
i was nervous and i was in my head about
it because like in the beginning like
you know
you know tasha was like drilling my head
you know what i'm saying because she was
so passionate about the work and i'm
like damn i don't [ __ ] up i'm hearing
like all these like notes and these
opinions and i'm like damn i don't even
know what the real terry terry's gonna
think you know what i'm saying uh about
my performance but you know i remember
after like the third episode came out he
reached out to me he was like yo man
like you you you you killing it and like
he was paying me homage on that don't
know how i portrayed him and i was like
yo this is
this is like this is it's like i want to
end it you know what i'm saying like i'm
hearing it from the man himself you know
what i'm saying like everyone else's
opinion
it matters but it don't matter as much
as him because as a dude you know what
i'm saying you watching yourself being
played like by another dude you know
what i'm saying you just think in that
male type of way and he was just like yo
i'm blown by the performance you know
what i'm saying and and um
i just honestly the way i locked in i
had a rough upbringing you know i'm
saying i grew up in brooklyn flatbush
and in orange east orange new jersey and
i'm saying it wasn't the best area and i
just drew from that and every hood is
the same you know i'm saying it's a
little different the lingo is different
but at the same
really it it's the same spirit like
every ghetto is the same so i just
tapped into that and i know brooklyn
would cross over so well with detroit
but uh
i've never i've never been in detroit
before in my life
only thing i was saying was what up
though and i sit and wear the little
high tops that they wore but in the top
tens but i was i was really just in my
brooklyn mindset from you know how i
grew up and then you know i just
took notes from from 50 from randy from
tasha from everyone else and and a
little meech it was it was a blessing
starring alongside him because he's the
source he was a plug so he's like my
personal google so i'm like yo bro is
this [ __ ] real is this
he's like you know putting me on game
how things were so it just it was the
right recipe and then you know we had
the veterans you got steve you got my
coal you got wood you got you know what
i'm saying russell so it's like it it's
like it's like steve was saying it was
the right
recipe and that four and a half years
away i definitely think it was righteous
you know what i'm saying
it was genius this was like a banger
like you know i fit
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you know i love that you said that
because the thing that's so interesting
about 50 is that he is a storyteller
he's a rapper he's an actor he's a
producer and he knows this i'm very
interested in and how you see the world
through television because i'm loving
the things that you are getting behind
but now you're also a director what made
you want to direct this episode in bmf
and and what did you kind of use to to
help push these actors to give us this
really great work that we see in this
episode well it was for me it was
for my first
time directing i directed on power yeah
in in
season six and
following that
you know i made sure that i wasn't
directing until it was a later episode
in the show i was
episode seven of eight
and by then
the cast kind of meshes together they
get into a groove everybody is
comfortable with
how they're shooting it even the
director photography is
already aligned himself
with how we're actually shooting the
show so i wouldn't be coming in doing
anything drastic to change the actual
show just add little things that i see
in films like i hate when the shots are
static shots like they're just
over the shoulder the same old thing and
you just listen hearing the dialogue so
i want to see the camera move do
different things that make it exciting
for me so i feel like something's
happening
i got to be paying attention to it if
there's no
just a project alone communicating with
the actors i already had that
relationship
so it's comfortable i think a big part
of
getting the right performance is just
being able to communicate what you're
trying to see in the scene
and the talent is there they
they didn't require much at that point
like be honest they just make me look
great
i'll tell you it's just like that like i
would say stay to sleep with it while
he's doing i said what you think about
this like how you feel about the the
scene itself when we when we actually go
on because and it i think that provides
a different comfort because sometimes
people that
don't have as much information about the
scene or a vision for it that
are directing at points
you know they haven't done it with the
same way that the
acting talent has and then when you
you're able to let we got that now
this is yours do you know do what you
feel like with this thing like you know
this offers something different and the
comfortability of being able to for them
to
knowing that these are the people that
you put in this position because you
know they know what they're doing
already not that there's a it's a point
where
we're auditioning for the scene because
you're trying to make some [ __ ] that
actually isn't on the paper
at that point
and that
that allowed it to be a smooth
transition i interesting things happen
to you at the same time because being a
producer and being invested in an entire
show we lost the entire locations
department during me
directing me
you know he had some issues and i had to
go
and communicate with them and it's a
good thing that i just used them as a
director to communicate with them to to
get all the locations locked down for
episode seven because the director for
episode 8 has spun the entire team off
for this awful show right i had to go
get them the back and
we just transitioned into doing what we
had to do from there but this is this
has been a roller coaster the entire way
and the payoff is amazing i think randy
is probably look
his this experience there's no one
running the show right now that had the
same experience
as
my show trust me it's just not even
close i believe you i believe you you
know this next question um is actually
for randy and 50 and maybe in some small
ways a little meech considering that
he's playing his dad and look i'm not
trying to get anybody in trouble let me
just say that right now but
how much of what we see
is fact versus fiction and how did you
guys decide what's to fictionalize and
what to keep as true to the story as
possible
um but i'm not trying anybody in trouble
no no i'll start off
that's a reasonable definitely a great
question yeah
and i'll just start off by saying
i still spent i mean i got an email this
morning so i mean i spend like every day
you know what i mean
talking to big meat and uh so there's
not a storyline in here that isn't based
on something i heard you know what i
mean but that said i'm a drama writer
not i'm not telling a documentary so a
documentary is based off facts well my
job is to entertain and make people jump
out they don't see so certain points i
have to take a left when they went
straight ahead or if they took a right
i'm like nah we got to go straight ahead
but it's still all based in stories that
i have heard over the past three years
from my interactions with big meech and
then when terry came home even talking
to terry and talking to miss lucille
flenery talking to so
it's all rooted from the truth you know
what i mean
in process i think the
you i have to tell randy not to
listen to them at points
because they get so you're so stressed
out there'll be so much information
coming and they wanted to see it just
they wanted to just show out that they
went like this
yeah so put the day in like that and
you're going no that's not how it works
man
like when do do what what fits the best
for the show a hundred percent
and then the rest of the rest of it you
look i i'll talk to them don't worry
about it i'll get on the phone with them
and deal with them because they don't
know until they see the results
when they watch now and they see the
public response to it they go yeah
do it go away
don't listen to what i was saying like
you know i mean
you look and
it's different and davinci hair grows so
fast that's a whole nother talent
is
[Laughter]
now you know before before i wrap you
guys up and i do want to go around the
zoom on this one um this story is so
rich and so fertile you know and
and i had said to uh to 50 before that
i'm already ready for you know like
season five you know because i know
what's gonna happen with the story we
all know how the story ends but we're
learning obviously how it kicked off and
all the kind of missing parts in between
but how far in advance randy have you
thought about um the story um and then
just would love to hear those of you who
are bringing these characters to life um
even if because we kind of know in some
ways what what happens to these
characters but what are your hopes with
uh with regard to the evolution of these
characters that you bought that you've
created but randy let's start with you
there um i think i've always seen
i mean look a successful tv show is a
show that goes five years i've always
thought we can do more than that i mean
you know what i mean i certainly have
been told by big meets that this is 10
years 15 if you don't mess it up it's
not like so
uh you know um but what's really
interesting about
the people you have on um our zoom right
now i certainly do see all of these
people
uh seeing this series all the way
through you know what i mean and that's
one of the most interesting things about
the series is that as they grow as they
expand
they're gonna have new crews you know
what i mean so it's gonna be interesting
like one of the things that i really
wanted to talk about about uh you know
detroit and the culture of detroit was
musically so we started in 86 you got to
hear the tech now you know season two
will be more late 80s 89 88 and you're
gonna see the influence of music popping
there we know in season three when he
goes to atlanta you know that south
music is going to be starting to pop so
just to go on this musical exploration
is something i'm most excited uh about
seeing and then also
like something i had to come up with you
know breaking season two
is uh steve harris's character you know
what i mean this is me taking dramatic
license but i want to see him in the end
you know what i mean and that will
really be full circle for his
relationship that he started with this
young man that he coached youth baseball
with you know what i mean so i'm really
excited about this journey that we are
and these actors that are going to bring
it to life for us
yeah nicole how about yourself what what
about lucille's evolution because she
obviously is like the moral compass of
the show um but what what are you kind
of hoping to to see if i get my dream of
at least five seasons of the show
oh lord five seasons i don't know but uh
i'll say this for now
i'm looking forward to her um really
letting go
and um
unapologetically stepping into her power
um i'm i'm looking forward to um
more scenes with the boys and and their
friends like that was one of the things
that the real miss lucille talked about
a lot you know that she would hang with
them she would cook with them for them
and stuff and really uh
she just spent a lot of time with them
and listening and she really cooks
her to
minister
outside of the church what you laughing
at
i said cook i said cook what
i see what you did there
randy write that in
don't you wake up the damage the whole
family is doing that
i love it i love it steve yourself
uh uh
man i like
three-dimensional
the character got to be full you know
you got you know i enjoy being a problem
i consider i'm gonna still continue to
be a problem that's that's part of what
i do uh i'm a little different because
i'm not you know it's not it's based
around a lot of true cats but that's not
one like little me playing as pops and
da vinci is playing t so for me it has
it's well-rounded you know these guys
and i think this is what people don't
get a lot of times guys uh
guys can be killers
and have a family at home be the most
loving dude you've ever seen with his
family right
and we always
uh one of the things that always beeps
me is that you know
you know
people making a lot of money look at
people on the street and think they're
stupid no they ain't
people on the street with the people
doing all this kind of funny talk or
whatever and thinking they ain't got it
hey
they're just two sides to the coin
they if you making it on the street
trust me you got some sense to you you
got more than that because of how you
have to deal with it the thing is can
you play on both
yeah you know what i mean that's the
thing when i play basketball i put on
cleats
i put on clicks play football i put on
cleats can you put on the right
equipment to play in both and that's
kind of the dynamic of my characters cop
kid do the dirt thing here he got a
family situation got going every dude
should have a chick with him you know
it's that whole thing and all that thing
has to affect what is going on and and
as as i'm sure uh randy is already doing
it if y'all noticed
i anticipate in all of this i anticipate
to be tested
the character must be tested that's part
of it and then the care go bring tests
to it you know what i mean so uh
i guess that's my testament
i like that that's it and and before we
before we wrap up uh little meech and da
vinci what about you guys because you
guys are the two young men that we're
going to be following uh throughout the
course of the series
yeah i can't wait just for people to see
because i want to portray you know my
dad for exactly who he is you know i
want people to see the actual loving
family man that he was you know he was
just so smart and hear all the obstacles
against him but you know he still made
the best out of it so i want people you
know because my dad always wanted people
to know the real him because there's
nothing out there but documentaries that
show what people know about him this is
you know the time and the chance for
everybody you know what type of family
he had how he grew up and exactly what
made him do what he did so i'm just
excited for everybody to see the you
know upcoming seasons that like randy
said hopefully we can go for 10.
i like that da vinci
i would just i would just like to see
the the brothers not arguing as much you
know i'm saying i think um
i think you know what i'm saying they
they brothers argue a lot but i think
there's some moments that
they definitely was just laughing and
joking especially when they were kids
you know what i'm saying like they
they wasn't arguing like 24 sec like
hours of the day like you know so a lot
of people just hit me up like damn y'all
[ __ ] always argue
and i was like damn now that i think of
it yeah we are always arguing in the
show and [ __ ] like that so i i would
like to
you know see that but other than that i
mean i think you know the way you know
they're writing the character i think
it's beautifully done you see the layers
of you know how he is with his family
he's trying to manage that in school
in the streets you know i think i think
it's i have no like you know what i'm
saying
i mean it's just the argument that
that's all i feel like you know what i'm
saying
we can chill out a little
bit well whatever you guys are gonna
gift us uh we are already ready for it
because this first season has been
really excellent uh bmf people thanks so
much for doing this today continued
success thank you for having us thank
you appreciate it appreciate you thank
you for having us all right all right
good seeing everyone man yeah be good
man
[Music]
you